we're going to draft our unsung heroes
from super bowl 54. chris has the trivia
question if i get it right i get dibs
otherwise he does all right ask me a
question i won't be able to answer here
we go you might be able to get this
before sunday andy reid was the actor
what was the active head coach with the
most career wins without a championship
you knew that now that reed has his
title
which current head coach has the most
wins without a lombardi trophy
current head coach most wins without a
lombardi trophy yes i'm buying time i'm
scanning through all the guys who have
been on the job a long time yeah and
they all have
well i'm thinking mike mccarthy he's got
one sean payton he's got one i mean
process of elimination i'd eventually
get there but we don't have enough time
to do it who would it be
is it who would it be it's got to be
it's got to be something not all that
obvious is it doug marone
[Music]
ron rivera ron rivera right you would
have got there i know i would have
gotten there yeah i got in there it's
hard it's hard when the camera's on you
and you know you're wasting a whole
segment by uh trying to figure out that
that uh answer to that question so
a lot of guys to sift through yes
they're around for a while um all right
so unsung hero first off i feel like
can you pick a 49er in the unsung hero
draft and it's not unsung chief i i know
i know but it just seems like you can
you be a hero on a losing would you lead
with a 49er i don't know but can you can
pick one no i'm gonna go with my unsung
hero and this is somebody you've heard
me talk about a lot the last two days
that's chris jones i'm going with chris
jones chris jones
was
huge in this football game i mean we
talk about big plays man you know big
players making big plays and big moments
well he's the reason jimmy garoppolo
threw the interception early on
he was
when there was a pressure applied to
garoppolo more times than not it was
because of chris jones then his ability
to get hands up in the passing lane not
only deflected a few balls but had some
other passes that his hands are in the
way and i think jimmy garoppolo had to
throw the ball a different way because
he realized that that big sucker was
there and trying to time out his
throwing but jones
is the second best player on the kansas
city chiefs for my money it goes mahomes
and jones he's a game changer when he's
in there and you know here you go
another slant round got his hands on
that i mean he had three batted balls in
the last two drives of the game that
were huge so chris jones
yeah i think that's a good pick and i
think it's fairly obvious but still a
good pick probably the guy would have
taken if i had the first election we
talked earlier about who would have been
the mvp if not patrick mahomes and you
suggested nick bosa well one of the
reasons nick bosa didn't rack up the mvp
one of the reasons the 49ers didn't win
eric fisher did a good job of containing
him right you can't stop him you can't
shut him down but he kept nick bosa from
effing up enough plays that would have
made it easier for the 49ers to win and
thing about offensive lineman
unless they are throwing guys into the
front row you don't notice when they're
doing their job well you only notice
when they're doing their job poorly so
fischer's a guy who deserves some credit
for not letting nick bosa destroy the
chief's offense yeah that that's fair i
mean you're right it destroys the word
we've seen that 49er d line right mike
destroy
like hey did he get beat or pushed
around in a few plays in the super bowl
certainly but he didn't get destroyed in
the fact that ma holmes didn't even have
time to react or process like what does
the pocket look like you know we saw in
games against green bay and in minnesota
where there were times there where you
know they caught the ball and their
offensive line had been destroyed as a
whole and there was nothing they can do
the chiefs were good enough at least to
buy my homes a little time to where he
could make magic get the ball out of his
hands and do that so i'm with you there
i'm going with spags uh i'm going with
spagnola the defensive coordinator of
the of the chiefs as my second pick i
mean uh to me
you know unsung hero for the whole 2019
season you know andy reid making that
change
spags yes it didn't start off pretty but
the defense just got better and better
and better and better to where we got to
the playoffs and you started to go damn
i don't really care where the chiefs are
ranked they're kind of playing defense
about as good as anybody in football you
know other than the 49ers they they had
become that force we saw them shut down
derrick henry and not that they shut
down shanahan in the run game but they
certainly didn't let it just dominate
the football game and control the clock
so i think between that and some of his
creativity and pass defense spags is uh
again an x factor in a super bowl just
like he was in 2007 helping the giants
beat the patriots
yeah and you wonder
whether that gets him on the radar
screen next year
for head coaching opportunities does he
get a second chance you know it was so
bad for him with the rams maybe he
doesn't but if the chiefs continue this
type of a run you're talking about a
head coach with an offensive background
if the defense plays well and vaults the
team to another championship how do you
not at some point lock on to steve
spagnuolo and convince yourself he's
ready for another opportunity to be a
head coach right next one for me
uh wha one of i i remember first hearing
the name bashad breeland yeah
this came up the first monday night of
the season
2016
josh norman
then in his first game with washington
after the panthers were sent to the
franchise tender they were playing the
steelers and people were like why the
hell is bashad breeland covering antonio
brown right they're paying josh norman
15 million a year he should be traveling
with antonio brown and rashad breeland
got torched that night well he didn't
get torched on
sunday and look it wasn't a wire to wire
great performance but he had a big
tackle of debo samuel on a screen pass
behind the line of scrimmage next play
he was right place right time for an
interception of jimmy garoppolo that
that kept the 49ers from
building an early lead it felt like they
were going to build a lead and keep a
lead and then the chiefs would have to
come back it didn't happen till the
second half one of the reasons it was
tied at 10 at halftime is breeland you
know get hey look uh hey you're supposed
to make that catch he was in the right
place at the right time but there's been
no mention of the guy in the aftermath
of the game i mean that's classic unsung
hero yeah no it is and and you know to
your point you know early this year
rashad breeland struggled i mean i think
you heard me on some sundays just going
oh oh what is it past interference by
breeland oh holding by breeland i mean
but as the year went on and the guy this
is a guy that's been injured and this is
you know he probably needed some time to
get totally 100
but yeah he was pretty awesome in the
football game he was and he was awesome
down the stretch of the season for the
kansas city chiefs and that was that was
a big interception you're right because
the first drive of the game
you know we saw the 49ers go down and
you went ooh it doesn't look good for
the chiefs and then that drive kind of
started off the same and you're going oh
man are the chiefs ever going to slow
them down and that did halt the momentum
of the 49ers at that point to make you
think whoa can the chiefs get up on them
14 to 3 what is it you know what can
happen here so uh great year by rashad
breeland um
i you know i mean i'm gonna go to nick
bosa all right i am i mean he was an
unsung hero the football game you know
yes you know eric fisher didn't let him
get a ton of sacks or do anything like
that but i think as a whole as i said
earlier in the show
he was the best defensive player on the
field nick bose i just can't say enough
about the guy
he's in the conversation for the best
defensive player in football already in
his rookie year he really is i mean he
is up there with stefan gilmore and
aaron donald
mike how many guys did we have to come
on radio row last week where we asked
what about the 49ers z who do you stop
every one of them said nick mosa it's
just so rare for a rookie pass rusher to
come in and have that effect and you
know i know they lost but he still uh
showed that he was really a a phenomenal
football player on sunday
you know i could go a lot of different
ways on this when i thought about debo
samuel um i thought he was he was great
we talked earlier yeah
i will go debo samuel yeah because
because he's
there was talk in the press box that if
the 49ers had won the game we're like
right he could have been the mvp of the
game i mean he had 39 yards receiving
and he added to that 53 yards rushing on
three attempts so i mean that is a quiet
92 yards from scrimmage and and he would
have had more if they would have used
him more that's the problem they should
have been using him in the second half
he put hell line him up in the backfield
man do something just get the ball in
the guy's hands it's obvious when he has
the ball in his hands he is better than
the guys who are trying to tackle him he
is he's got a special way he's just so
explosive he you know he can go zero to
60 in two steps and he's just fearless
running the football and you're right
you know my little boy voted on the mvp
like eight minutes left in the fourth
quarter and voted on br you know for for
devo samuel too you know but then it got
to three minutes in the fourth quarter
and he was like wait wait wait i gotta
change my pick i gotta change my pick
but breeland was amazing and hey that
was another one you know stats just said
this in my ear i mean you know bosa with
the first pick debo samuel the second
pick all the benefits of going from four
and 12 two years ago you know they
struck and made those two picks in the
top 35 or 36 whatever it was they made
them count and those players contributed
to their football team
thanks for nothing thanks for everything
yes there is a benefit to being bad if
you know how to use those picks yeah one
of the reasons why i think these teams
have staying power they know how to use
their picks yeah how about some other
possibilities we got a couple more
minutes here i was thinking to go on
sammy watkins sure uh you know he had
almost 100 receiving yards very quietly
and he had he had five catches on six
targets and you know tyreek hill had 105
receiving yards and that long play from
the 22 to the 22 20 what is it two three
jet chip wasp right we give mahomes the
credit but if you're not tyree kill if
you don't have that speed and
explosiveness you're not wide open no
exactly right i mean again that you know
there's just there's not really a
quarterback wide receiver combo like
that in football they're one of the few
teams that can pull that off that play
in general have enough pass protection
to block those guys those freaks of
nature up front just long enough to
where my homes can launch it yeah not a
lot of people are going to dial that up
that way
but yes tyree kill was he was really
good in the football game you know and
makes himself available when mahomes was
trying to scramble around and do things
you said it's sammy watkins you know he
certainly had some big moments in the
football game um
i even thought like
you know just to get away from football
a second hey i i had demi lovato on my
list i thought the national anthem was
like out of this world good you know
whitney houston will always be number
one to me but damn demi lovato put
herself in the conversation i think for
like the fight for number two right with
the national anthem i don't know what it
sounded like on person but she killed it
on tv and it sounded like the crowd
realized she killed it anistat said she
hit the under too so there's some people
out there even happier with the
performance than they otherwise would
have been all right uh let's take a
break and we'll wrap up this tuesday
edition of pft live when we return right
after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports